(cheerful music)
- [Voiceover] Blakely has
the most difficult job
in Cincinnati Zoo, he has to
play with babies all the time.
(squeaking)
(hissing)
He's never shown any
aggression or snapped.
If he gets upset, kinda
like any mom would,
he just leaves the room. (laughing)
- [Voiceover] You are so cute!
- My name is Dawn Strasser, and we're
at the Cincinnati Zoo and Botanical Garden
Blakely is a five year
old Australian Shepherd.
We got him from a rescue.
And I use him in the nursery
as a nanny, or companion dog.
This is about you, and
you're taking a nap!
Blakely's here for the main
purpose of teaching the babies
the correct animal cues as they grow up,
so when they are introduced
back to their own kind,
they know what appropriate behavior is.
He teaches them how to
play, how to interact.
I can tell them, no don't
bite me, but I'm not an animal
and I don't give the
same cues that he can.
So we make a great team.
(cheerful music)
- [Voiceover] Smile for the camera!
- [Dawn] Blakely has worked
with cheetahs, ocelots,
a takin, bat-eared foxes, a warthog,
wallabies, to name a few.
He's working with four
baby cheetahs right now.
It's been a long seven weeks for him
with these little cheetah
cubs, and he's, I think, tired.
He's on alert for 24 hours a day.
If they start making too much
noise, he'll come and get us.
Like, something's not right,
something's not right.
He's kinda like a second
set of eyes for us, too.
A lot of times they still
recognize each other,
like Dale the takin he raised,
when they see each other,
Dale'll still run up in
front and grunt at him,
and he'll kinda jump up on
the wall and it’s kinda like,
hey, how ya doin'?
- He's beautiful.
- [Dawn] Thank you!
Yeah, well, I like to
think I have an office,
but I'm pretty sure it's his.
(light cheerful music)